um so we're going I think so we're going
to start now uh so this session going to
be about Comics andai bys Le
so should
I hello everyone thank you so much for
waiting thank you uh so thank you uh
this is my talk Comics at numpy more
likely than you think and so as you
already seen in the in the seats in
front of you there are comics and in
these Comics are so many beautiful
things but I really want to say you get
a comic you get a comic everyone gets a
comic and everyone gets a comic because
I literally promised everyone that I
would so here we have that um and if you
are watching remotely or online and you
do not have a comic in hand do not worry
there is a digital version as well
here's the QR code and a URL if you're a
quick fingered masochist and if you get
a digital version you can also Download
a pdf and with a PDF you could print it
out and make more copies and very
reasonable number of copies on the
office printer you certainly have
permission to use and then you can drop
off more copies to your coworker friends
dogs and loved ones and I think people
in this room already have a head start
uh reading the comics but if you haven't
finished it yet don't worry we'll go
through it so okay enough Shenanigans
let's get straight to the
talk uh psych actually here's a really
quick introduction to me I'm Mar and I'm
looking for a job and prepare for the
strangest job interview of your life so
imagine you're reading documentation
you're doing your due diligence
understanding how a library or API
works but it's pretty dry boring even
page after page you're reading and not
really understanding you flip back and
forth trying to find that one thing you
need you start thinking to yourself
where did things go
along I can't answer the last question
but but I can answer the first one about
documentation and the answer is Comics
documentation as Comics yeah but wait
you may be asking yourself what why
how very reasonable question Comics wait
H actually that doesn't really make much
sense so I'll go an overview of it in my
talk here so in this uh overview will
cover some of the comic itself the
origins of it the The Inspirations the
brainstorming how we taking feedback
narrowing it down peeking into the
artist studio see how it all works and
then finally um kind of like how do we
integrate all this stuff together and
then some unusual and interesting final
section welome back to
that so the comics tells story of three
students two midterms One open source
library and in these Comics you can see
how noai is Ed how to use numai oh wait
this is a little painful can we improve
this yes we can because numai is open
source wait what is open source and how
do we contribute to numpy and then the
bigger story is numai is built by the
people who use it who are scientists and
students and so we have our opening
establishing shop of the students at the
very extinguished University of Monty
and they just finished a lab and they
needed to look at the sell images with
numpy but one of them doesn't know how
to use numpy thankfully another does so
they all help each other the comics move
between the story and Technical
information here is a big one on why use
mpai in microbiology why arrays instead
of images you can read this more fully
on page
two and then we kind of follow a step by
step as the student say they use
numai however you know how you start
doing something because it looks easy
and then becomes increasingly difficult
and you can't step away from it because
no no I I got it this time I swear
that's what this entire page three is
about is about feeling that way with
naai a student bursts in wait why why
why are we doing this why is numai like
that this is a huge usability problem I
can't easily see the mpz the file
name and now we have this back and forth
this dial dialog of well you just need
to do things uh in this specific exact
way and everything will work except for
that one thing but otherwise everything
will be
fine and you know each student has a
different approach to this one is
accepting numai as it is one is a bit
critical numpy can be better and the
last one agrees numpy can be better and
we can make it
better so we have a brief introduction
to the to the wide beautiful world of
Open Source and open science to strive
for the ideals and values to build the
tools that make scientific research more
collaborative and
transparent but for all this talk of
ideals what are we actually supposed to
do how do we make it better what are the
steps and so what are the steps in
contributing what about issues and
GitHub and what are all these things
well don't worry they're going to figure
it out together they are going to muck
around and find out so we then have five
more pages of Step by Step going through
n.org looking at GitHub five more pages
of the nerve-wracking anxiety of writing
your first issue five more pages of
explaining the contributor workflow and
yes I hate to say it but I'll say it
read the docs read the comics it'll tell
you everything you know what happens in
these next five
pages so that was an overview of the
comics now let's get into the origins
how did this all start well it started
last year at
scipi and I handed out 300 comics and
these Comics were how to write Alex for
scientific diagrams and documentation
and in these uh I gave a 5 minute Lang
talk about it so thank you David for
hosting that session and the comics were
inspired by these workshops that I
co-hosted with Isabella and much like I
am now pitching and selling the idea
comics comics as documentation and there
a lot of are the same reasons that I'm
talking about today which is about
having a story humor and emotion and
saying that there's a human heart a
reason of what we do and what we're
trying to
solve and also it's collaborative it's
tactile I convince my friends to help me
fold in the staple a bunch of comics
certainly not an hour before the
lightning talk and so when I left that
experience I felt really happy that I
pulled this off and it made me want want
to pull it off again and so I started
thinking okay what else could I make
comics for well I already been
contributing to numai for 3 years I've
been helping out with a website and
writing meaning notes and I started to
like develop like an idea or a prototype
of comic in my head and this is based
off some conversations last year about
uh contribution and maintainer
Pathways um and these were conversations
that were mostly happening in the
meeting minutes um and that they're kind
of like big picture and so I made a
picture and I made a GitHub issue to
talk about it and then I got a feedback
from it on the numai newcomers hour and
then I continue to share it with other
artists on open- Source um design
forums so basically I've been shopping
around for a few months with the idea
going door to door like a Salesman
people L nodding and smiling but not
quite
biting and then emerged the Google
season of
docks my hero my Nemesis my everything
you shall see see um so this came some
months later and I had the option of
submitting a proposal and the thing is I
have never worked on an academic Grant
I've never done the whole Chang how this
felt to me was more of a pitch kind of
like Disney Animation or when you pitch
a story you pitch something for a studio
to fund it to make it
happen and I submitted this with the
project mentors mukulika and
Ross and I was like okay I know how to
make comics but I got to prove it to
people so they can G can give me money
and so I did the whole project Road
mapap I did timelines budgets Key
Personnel all these things to say please
please and I got accepted woo along with
some other uh Scientific Python projects
I was so happy you know let's let's go
let's go let's go
but wait I have ridden myself into a
corner because I
realized there are some differences in
my knowledge of a growing Niche field of
out text in an open source library of
over 15 years
another way of saying it that there are
some one place there's a fewer players
in the other there's a lot in fact over
32,000 packages on GitHub depend on noai
and over 6 million users on the website
every month suddenly I was feeling a lot
more pressure and I was feeling a lot
more eyeballs on what I was
doing and so it's kind of like a cash 22
where I'm building on existing work but
also creating something new I'm telling
a story but still telling technical
information and it has to be driven by
Community but also show my own
individual artistic Vision it's innovate
respect innovate respect can I do
both and I realized let's just look at
existing work that already does both and
great let's get inspired let's see what
I was inspired by and there's a whole
list of all sorts of things and all
sorts of different thingies and all goes
in pretty quickly because what really
matters is how it all comes together
there is of course the existing numpy
documentation there is the ongoing numai
documentation meetings that happen every
two weeks there is a the DI taxis
framework which is something the numpy
doc team has been working with to kind
of organize the
information and if we say use that
framework perhaps my comments could fit
under
tutorials but it's not really clear fit
there either there's already people who
are talking about contributor experience
such as Alissa andessa Noah and they
have their own whole talk talking about
all these very smart things there is the
manga's guide which is fun and cute I
like that and there is the Turing way
which is bit more focused on
reproducible scientific research in
again a Community Driven way so I have
all these different things and I'm
telling you I'm telling you there is
there's a way they all con connect
together and I know it doesn't make
sense and there's like eight different
things but it will because what we're
doing is taking best existing best
practices and pushing it over
there and if you know a thing or two
about animation you would know that when
Patrick was pushing the thing there was
a frame in between there was a frame in
between where all this
inspiration turns into a comic it turns
into an actual product that you're
holding your hand right now now and so
the question is now how how did this
happen how did we turn this Alchemy like
into
wisdom and so this is where I go into
you know the nitty the gritty the the
underground the comic making process and
uh us Lees we know a thing or two about
making
Comics so when it comes to making Comics
it's not it's fun but it's not magical
there's a lot of different steps as you
can see and so we already went for the
first two and then we have to figure out
the rest with the NP
community and so with brainstorming um I
was basically asking domain experts on
something they don't have domain
expertise on Comics um and so I kind of
had to act as the domain expert over
there and find the middle
CR um and the thing is with uh Community
meetings they like hackmd they like to
structure their things down document it
makes perfect sense I didn't want to use
hackmd for brainstorming that felt a
little stilted it it's a format that
reinforces the Primacy of words over
images and I wanted to nudge it in the
other
direction I wanted to these domain
experts to feel like they're writers
that they're storyboard artists and that
we're sharing that same electrifying
energy of creativity and unlimited
possibilities and so I landed up on on
Google Jam board which is a digital
whiteboard and of the digital whiteboard
anyone could read comments sticky notes
add and draw images even draw like
little things with their
mouth and so I Jam boarded on my
prototype and I ended up hosting 20
minute sessions uh across three
different Community calls announcing on
the mailing list and everything and it
was really interesting how these three
different communities responded to the
same prototype uh with newcomers there
was a bit more focus on nonlinear
Pathways that they're multiple ways that
you can contribute and it's not just
code at the docs meeting there was some
questioning about the the metaphor
contribution Pathways and how that
metaphor may fall
flat and then a community meeting there
was um it's kind of repeating an ongoing
conversation the difficulty quantifying
the unquantified iable like if you say
you do close five issues do that mean
you gain the rights on a repository you
can't really promise anything like that
but we're trying to chart something
out and so I then had to consolidate the
feedback from three different
stakeholders to use business terms and
so how do I bring all these three
different threads
together what I certainly did not want
to do was designed by committee and I'm
sure you've seen very long disjointed
documentation that does the job but
doesn't really have like an overarching
narrative or a way to kind of convince
you all the way through and so I decided
okay you know what I need to do is I've
listened to the community and I'm going
to now listen to myself for a bit I'm
going to squirrel away and think okay
what do I take away from all this and
what really helped in this process was
talking to other artists
because when I was in the numai space I
was basically the only artist and I felt
comfortable sharing my expertise but
it's something really valuable
electrifying and sharing with the artist
someone who gets the same way that you
do and this was Tony fast who's a fellow
artist Open Source Advocate Muse and
editor and so we talked about comic
Theory B house all sorts of other things
that you see
here and in narrowing it down I realized
I should
actually just tell one story I was
trying to chart out multiple stories in
this diagram because over my 3 years in
the num Community I could see all the
different experiences and I want to try
every single one out but that doesn't
really tell one clear coherent
story um I wanted to do it almost
anthropologically and I realized I have
to come back to it as a
story and so I decided Ed wait I have
something that I could use based on a
true story and this is based off Ross
who is a project Mentor who works at
Berkeley Institute of data science and
he talked about a real um issue then
turn PR where his students had
difficulties uh navigating and opening
the mpz files in the numai and to numpy
for their Stell
images and so this issue then became a
PR that someone actually you know took
the time to address and so I realized
wait we have narrative
potential and so now we have to turn
these two things into a
story and again how how how how you we
we are peeking into the artist studio
where the magic happens but again it
feels kind of intense uh how again are
these two things
stories their screenshots their Pages
their lived experiences that I don't
have um and so I had to again just kind
of come back to my tools my processes
and then continue to find a middle in
all
that um so in terms of tools I want to
get something out of the way first yes
this is all handrawn there is no AI
there is no filters there is no
algorithms that was not built uh
programmatically I would like to do some
things like that in the future but this
this is like form to table except the
farm is my hand and the tables your eyes
don't think about it too
much and so these tools my hands a
10-year-old lockum tablet CR which is an
open source graphic software these are
things that um it's pretty uh simple to
access and something that you could
actually start doing yourself as
well writing a script
this is kind of where um pedals to the
metal where you just have to figure it
out and kind of jump between the big
picture and the small picture and this
ended up being a 12-page Google Document
covering 16 pages of a comic where the
narrative rise and the fall and the
character we add arcs remove
them and I had to come back to the
overarching story number is made by the
people who use it scientist but also the
emotional core of scratch my itch or I
was just describe with the mpz file
problem earlier oh I also have a problem
you know dealing with mpz files this
person brought up an issue I want to fix
it and
so taking that and bringing it now
mixing it in the characters so these
characters here I describe them as
having having three stoes energy and
these three
stoes they love and hate each other in
ways that I think are quite entertaining
um we have one that really likes to get
into nitty-gritty that likes to think
that likes to
explore we have one that's kind of more
of the straight man in the
middle maybe that's all right with me
and then you have one that's falling
more of like why are things like that
pushing back and so you can see this
happen over these three panels here and
how that kind of build off each other
these kind of interactions and kind of
like externalizing some thoughts I'm
sure we've all had in our heads but
making them into characters who again
love and hate each
other um another aspect was building
visual metaphors
so uh three examples one of them is
writing an issue and for me I wanted to
show writing an issue kind of like
putting something up on a community
bulletin board that others will see
maybe comment on and that we could build
from
there another metaphor um visually was
kind of explaining num pies and arrays
and the idea of zipping and unzipping
and why it's worthwhile to uh analyze
images in that
way and another visual metaphor was
taking you know the idea of open science
and making it into a globe that we're
all interconnected did and you know
helping each other
out so in a page by Page process this
involves thumbnailing to the script
panel layout and flow laying out
dialogue and speech bubbles photos
shoping get have screenshots first pass
final pass
editing the specifics of that um You
probably learn more from Scott McLoud
understanding Comics such an important
seminal work I'm just kind of showing
you the highlights on my side so this is
a quick uh
three-part uh process where the first
one is the script the second one are my
uh sketches that I made in my Sketchbook
and pencil and then the final product
and these sketches are honestly pretty
rough because I already have a good idea
of what I'm making in my head and the
hard part is actually arranging
everything into a panel that is readable
that is understandable
here's another one um this one is with
page five and you can see there's big
chunk missing in the middle again I just
I was more focused on the composition
than the details and so that's why the
world there is just three circles
keeping the big picture in
mind so I have all that I have swirled
away I have worked with artists and I
have created
something how do do we review it how do
we PR review the comic there are some
things that we can see some parallels um
we could see parallels in like writing
scripts code I we could put like a PR
for that but what about
illustrations um that is something that
usually takes a bit more time to develop
the visual language for and kind of like
a critique back and forth Artist Artist
and so for me
I wanted to integrate the artistic
process to existing open source
processes and
platforms and
so I made a GitHub
issue an oldie but a Goldie and a place
to park um all the conversations that
we've been having over the different
Community
meetings and so reviewing it was a
similar process to brainstorming where I
announce it on the mailing list I
present sketches and call I mean scripts
and then comments can be given in the in
the NP call the GitHub or the Google Doc
and so you can see here comments that
people left on both of
them along with me transcribing the
feedback from the calls and kind of
consolidating all these different
platforms into
one and another part was I made sure to
ask specific parts for feedback um so I
have like bullet pointed list about um
them storytelling accuracy and kind of
like um really directing what I'm
looking
for and
so PR reviewing a comic means explaining
my domain knowledge and the artistic
process integrating it into existing
platforms and invite the other side in
specific and engaging
ways I also made a repository of all the
artifacts in the same way one would do a
code
contribution and so we have these four
main things integration explanation
processes domain expert but after months
and months of doing this I started to
feel something familiar and a little
uncomfortable the grant was going great
but my mind was not I started to kind of
tip into the other side thinking I'm
simulation simplification
processes
okay um and I started think in in these
kind of other words and it started to
tip to the other side and I started
asking why why am I feeling like this
and so we come to the final section we
come back to the why so four years ago
almost to this very day in the same
building and possibly the same room I
was at p in New York City 2019 as a
diversity scholar and I gave a five
minute Lang talk about comics much like
I am doing now and some of you might
recognize coat Sprite I know you did all
you were in the audience four years ago
and someone else was in that audience
too it was Ralph the director of quanite
labs and once I finished my talk I was
offered a position there and in fact I
read a whole blog post about the
incredible transformed experience so
diversity scholars in the audience I
know you're out there cuz I talk to
Alina the organizer for this year this
could also be your chance and I tried I
really take full advantage of that job
and the opportunity that it gave me I
made comics on Alexs I hosted workshops
I traveled the country and the world and
now in Full Circle I'm given a platform
to talk about what I learned but do you
remember the title of the talk Comics
and npie More likely than you think the
entitle of why comic shouldn't be a npie
or you wouldn't think so and I spent a
whole to 20 minutes telling you yes
Comics can but the title is based off
this incredibly old me
and is a meme that is about removing The
Unwanted removing the unexpected uhoh
get rid of that and so at a grant was
going great like I said my mind wasn't
and so I kind of asked kind of
ironically enough going back to the why
am I worth the investment am I worth the
risk the
budget um I have to keep doing this cuz
I set the path forward for others like
me who are waiting for their own
opportunities I have to prove Pro the
world that someone like me is worth
keeping and so somewhere along the way I
turned away from my friends my partner
my hobbies are turned away from it all
so I could continue to do more work to
prove that this is worth it I had to
complete 16 pages I promis by the grand
deadline I have to I have to I have to
to prove the ideals of the gr of open
source of art but after talking to my
therapists and my friends I realized
that I'm not the only one there are a
few others out there like me and it is
difficult for us but I don't need to
burn myself to prove that there is light
in the world I can't let myself be a
murdered I am not good despite who I am
I'm good enough as is and so I made the
decision instead of thinking I have to
do this I decided to think well what do
I want to do what will make me happy and
whole and I decided yes I went to an emo
party when crowd surfing for the first
time yeah I tabled for a hacker space at
the con Island maker Fair that's where I
re in Brooklyn home of NYC resistor I
dressed up for Halloween and yes that is
the Spider-Man I invented silly games
and hacky Contraptions to staple Comics
shout out to my man John I told you told
you be here I brought a bunch of friends
some of them to a hacker space called
hive76 in Philadelphia and I met this
guy
even at the maker fair I modeled for a
home assistant an open source home
automation software their new logo and
merch paus and Melina I'm waiting for my
influencer t-shirt in the
mail and so all this to kind of say
that just besides just me there's also
how can we do better to support the
underrepresented skills peoples and
backgrounds in Scientific Python and I
would say specifically for those who
feel like they are this group it's good
to reach out to groups with similar
skills and background such as open
source
design that you should reconnect with
your communities and your allies and to
if you can step away from the pressure
of being the only
one so spoiler alert I didn't finish
everything I wanted and that's fine I
talk to the project mentors about it and
I'll continue to make the rest of my
pages on my own time this open source
after all the grand kickstarted the
comics but it doesn't end it either
and so what's next is I want to continue
to make art for communities I want to
share it at other places maybe sci-fi
Devcon K communication Camp no starch
press if you're out there please get
back to
me um I do want to step away from art as
a full-time job but I want to inspire
others to make art after sharing my
process tools and experience I'm proud
I'm happy I'm ready to walk away and let
others take over and well I've been
doing some deep soul searching recently
and the answer to what's next is a job I
did tell you this would be the strangest
job interview of your life so if you
have any of that you can email me Mars
barley gmail.com hit me on LinkedIn to
see my portfolio and that's it that's
the end of my talk thank you everyone
for coming it's I hope you enjoy your n
if you want more comments you can always
look for me the hall if you're here and
if you're watching online you can also
get your your everything else marsbar
ley.com don't forget to subscribe to the
MCU the Mars comic Universe some on
Twitter M Instagram and Linkedin thank
you and good
night